hello everyone
this is the 2021 finzi contini lecture
at the whitney humanities center
i'm paul north the interim director
alice kaplan the current director will
be back in the spring
[Music]
i'm thinking of a contrast in the movie
by vittorio de sica from 1971
called the garden of finzi continues
desicca shows the huge generosity of
spirit of this italian jewish family and
then the shock and dismay when they're
brutally displaced by fascists and
anti-semites
a tennis court and milan full of young
people at the beginning of the film a
painfully empty tennis court at the end
both of those characteristics are
present each year in this lecture named
after the family when the family's
continuing generosity makes it possible
to hear a literary writer who is often
writing from the thick of current global
crises
the finsi continue was endowed in 1990
by the honorable guido calabresi judge
u.s court of appeals for the second
circuit and former dean of the yale law
school and by his brother the late dr
paul calabrese
the lecturer honors their mother
grandmother and great-grandmother
speaking of the family as a whole bianca
maria finzicontini calabrese she and her
husband massimo calabrese activists in
the resistance against italian fascism
fled italy in 1939 after the passage of
the first infamous racial laws
they settled in new haven to start anew
he as a physician she as a literary
scholar
bianca maria finzee cantini calabrese
earned her phd in french at yale in 1949
with a dissertation on ernest reynon
her subject was one of the most
fascinating writers of the 19th century
a liberal and a brilliant analyst of
nationalism and christianity who
believed in racial hierarchies but
nonetheless counted among his enemies
the most vicious anti-semites in france
her thesis was directed by on repair the
european exiled from paris who wanted to
see her appointed to the faculty at yale
but the 1949 yale corporation refused
there would be no tenured women on the
faculty at yale for another three years
bianca maria finzicontini calabresi was
undeterred
she went on to become professor of
french and italian at connecticut
college and then chair of the department
of italian at albertus magnus college
her last published volume also written
in french was on reynan's friendship
with emil eiger one of the founders of
classic philology
she died in 1982 at the age of 80.
we wish to thank judge calabrese and his
family for their generosity and for
giving us the privilege of remembering
our distinguished alumna bianca maria
finci continue calabresi
greetings to the three generations of
calabresis who are in the audience this
evening
the finsi cantini lecture sponsors a
distinguished speaker in the field of
comparative literature broadly defined
in 1991 the inaugural lecture was given
by the great italian semiotician umberto
ecco
subsequent lectures in the series have
been given by a now long list of eminent
writers from around the world including
sveton todorov a.s bayat orhan pamok
masha gessen hazar nafizi and maxine
hong kingston among many others
beginning with our march 2021 finzee
continue lecture the yale review has
joined the whitney as co-sponsor
please look for today's talk in print in
its pages and online
[Music]
race off will appear in the fall 2021
issue of the yale review edited by megan
o'rourke who we thank for all her help
now let me welcome namwali serpal
professor professor of english at
harvard
previously a professor at the university
of california berkeley literary critic
theorist of colonialism and global
struggles around race and post
coloniality and just as importantly a
fiction writer of note
her first public published story
was selected for the best american short
stories 2009 and shortlisted for the
2010 kane prize for african writing
she also won the 2015 kane prize for her
story the sack
her first book of literary criticism
called seven modes of uncertainty was
published by harvard university press in
2014 and her first novel the old drift
came out with hogarth press in 2019 and
won accolades as diverse as the
ennisfield wolf book award for fiction
and the arthur c clarke award for
science fiction as well as being
included among the hundred notable books
of 2019 by the new york times and time
magazines 100 must read books of the
year
must read books
about those words must and read
they really don't go together or
shouldn't
aesthetic experience is supposed to be
free in a way that the moral must
doesn't allow
we can read about all sorts of things
that we should by no means then go and
do
for serpent literature is free in this
way it quote enlivens and quote
activates i'm quoting from seven modes
of uncertainty
but there's a special obligation present
too
there's a longer quote from that book
quote literature produces free choice we
have to decide what something means
but this free choice is forced on us by
the text
this is a line from the scholarly and
critical book from 2014 seven modes of
uncertainty and you can see how she's
changing up the obligation
as a reader you choose what something
means freely but you have no choice but
to choose
so how do you do it
the first step is to recognize
uncertainty
uncertainty is not primarily an
epistemic problem a problem with
knowledge
i don't know or i don't know whether i
know or not which is bad enough
but it's a problem that lies in quote
the recesses of the word ethics
maybe i should act and maybe i shouldn't
maybe what i'm doing or plan to do won't
even count as action in this singular
and complex scenario
when encountering a complex scene in
literature this is one step more
difficult do i read a scene this way or
that or can it be read in both ways at
once
this is the highest point of tension for
literary critics where they usually give
up and say
many interpretations are possible
serpel tarries with detention
we can't give up either interpretation
situations are by nature compound coming
from multiple perspectives and multiple
pasts and heading toward multiple
futures
what is to be done
this is where a reader of literature
confronts the conundrum of ethical
judgment in a direct and unabashed way
and this is a good thought with which to
approach the old drift serpel's
prize-winning novel
i quote from the wyndham campbell
website which awarded her its
prestigious prize in 2020 quote
the old drift tells the story of three
families
with people of african european and
indian descent living in zambia over the
course of 200 years part historical
adventure part psychology psychological
realism part futuristic thriller and
part magical realism the novel is an
audacious lush sprawling and altogether
brilliant celebration of the artifice of
fiction
it's also a laboratory for readerly
ethics
for the beginning of the novel percy m
clark a white european arrives at the
old drift that part of the zambezi river
that's not too dangerous to be crossed
clark is a pathetic minor sad version of
a cecil rhodes
an imperialist of the small whose casual
and unquestioned racism and thoughtless
day-to-day brutality you can never
accept
and yet the routine hardships of his
life losing a baby struggling to earn
enough
fitting his meager intelligence into the
colonial hierarchies make the ethical
judgment harder and more pressing
what would judging and sentencing this
colonists do
what would it have done
devastation and domination happen
through a million almost normal lives
like this one or rather the almost
normal as i came to feel electrically in
my bones when reading the book
is riddled with horrors
clark shoots a black boy in the back
with buckshot mistaking him for an
animal in the brush
i want to single out an important
insight here that once the imperial
project is set up horrors come to look
like collateral damage and what to do
with an indirect evil that is almost
coincident with normal life was very
vocabulary collateral damage conceals it
again this is the main task of an ethics
of uncertainty and ethics of reading
one answer is to allow a response to let
the other side speak which serpal does
in addenda to each chapter where a
pre-national even pre-human collective
judges from a cold unsympathetic
distance
the book is responded to by a chorus of
mosquitoes who tell us about the
unconquerable parts of the conquered
space
parts that are too big too hot to wet
that change too much full of
uncertainties
quote
this is what the mosquitoes say
evolution forged the entirety of life
using only one tool the mistake
unquote
as you can see professor serpal doesn't
run away from complexity
and her project of a non-simplifying
ethical education continues
she wants the fullest possible
description of a scene and recognition
of its singular conditions and multiple
perspectives before anyone is allowed to
say must
i believe we're being invited to follow
her tonight doing something similar in
her lecture race off the fantasy of race
transformation
after the lecture there'll be a
conversation with tina post who is
assistant professor of english and
theater and performance at the
university of chicago and a recent
alumna of yale as professor serpal
herself is though in the more distant
past
before i present
professor serpal i want to mention a
couple of issues
when you want to ask a question please
feel free to do it you can put your
questions in the q a at any time
chat will be disabled as will hand
raising but you're free as i say to add
your questions all the way through
when i read the questions at the end in
the q a i will be
eliding people's names for rights
reasons
so now without any further talk from me
please join me in welcoming professor
namwali serkau
hello everyone
thank you so much for that wonderful and
complex introduction paul
i'm going to share my screen and launch
right into my presentation
which is called race off
the fantasy of race transformation
american race transformation
and it should be
about 50 minutes
what if you could change your race
some disturbing scandals of late have
put this hypothetical to the reality
test
a cluster of white american academics
and activists
many of them women it seems have been
revealed to have spent years cosplaying
a different race
latinx
black native american
misleading if not outright deceiving
their colleagues and comrades
such deceptions are nothing new
in the mid-19th century pt barnum
showcased people of concocted races such
as the circassian girl or the circassian
beauty
barnum also promoted a negro
william camel who claimed to have
discovered a weed that turns a black
person white
newspaper newspapers at the time called
out runaway slave imposters
at the same moment white writers were
publishing fake slave narratives
in his 2017 history bunk
kevin young notes that the hoax
regularly steps in when race rears its
head
exactly because it too is a fake thing
pretending to be real
indeed historical evidence and
scientific consensus both tell us that
race is a social rather than a
biological reality
yet we harbor a near atavistic obsession
with the methods and motives of race
fakers
how do they change their skin
their hair
their voice
their origin story
and why is it minstrelsy is it white
guilt
is it fetishism
some have argued that being not white
has come to seem politically profitable
suffering is now established as a form
of cultural capital
today i want to suggest to you that
these recent race fakers are merely the
latest players in a game i call the
fantasy of american race
transformation if we take a lead from pt
barnum we can taxonomize this genre
along various axes when these texts
appeared and who produce them which race
gets transformed and into what race
what mechanism catalyzes it and how
is it imposed or self-motivated and to
what end
is it reversible or permanent
while there's a veritable circus of
racial chimeras to consider i'll train
my spotlight today on the
transformations between black and white
people and popular narrative works
created by black and white americans
from the 1850s to now
from passing
to cross-racial reportage to speculative
fiction
the fantasy of race transformation cuts
an electric line thrilling dangerous
illuminating through the american
popular imagination
at first glance there might seem to be
something radical in the very idea of
changing your race which assumes that
race is changeable and therefore unfixed
in short a construct
but what we find is that all the
aesthetic energy and race transformation
stories
springs from the surprise of a black
person inside a white person or vice
versa
and this of course assumes an essential
racial soul
lurking within the transformed body with
this in mind we see that to change your
race is really just a kind of thought
experiment
geared to make you empathize with
another race to punish you for being
bigoted or to grant you brief giddy
access to being another person a kind of
racial exoticism or slumming that lets
you transcend
the suffocation of social divisions
immediately yet impermanently
race transformation tales offer the
promise of escaping the body
but they often end up making that body
abject or an object
in this sense
this genre reinscribes racism rather
than rising above it
but it does give us some insight
not into what race actually is
but into what we think it is and
naturally what we think it is
very much depends on who we mean by we
let me introduce you to this race
transformation circus
the grounds
are passing narratives
in which a person deemed by law
to be black has features that pass for
white
the passing narrative first appeared in
19th century drama
and was popularized during the harlem
renaissance by writers such as james
baldwin johnson and nella larson
cairo scoro high contrast between dark
and light is a common aesthetic in
passing literature
melodramatic sentiments of fear taboo
desire
and despair predominate
it's tragic
sad and grand
and in passing narratives miscegenation
usually via the rape of enslaved black
women takes generations to yield a
dramatic change in the racial appearance
of a family
only then do we find the melancholy
tragic mulatto distraught at the
injustice of the one drop rule that
banishes them from full subject hood
torn
between
the white world and the black world
as the word passing implies
passing is gradual
it moves like a wave over generations
drowning some
wrecking others on the reefs of guilt
and grief and always moves in one
direction toward the foamy crest of
whiteness
it's a lose-lose game
passing merely replaces the social death
of racism with the social death of
isolation
it trades the pain of injustice
for the loss of culture and community
the critic allison hobbs puts it
succinctly
racial passing is an exile
when
james walden johnson's ex-colored man
chooses to pass he says
i have sold my birthright for a mess of
pottage
passing literature can culminate with
not just a figurative death but a
literal passing over to the other side
as in the fate of one character inela
larson's 1929 passing which has just
been made into a film that's due out
next year directed by rebecca hall
and some of you may have seen the
preview came out just yesterday
despite these perhaps dark morbid
connotations white americans soon wanted
in on passing
it portended greater melancholy greater
melodrama than the fakeries of slave
imposters in the grotesqueries of
and so we come to exhibit a of our show
for today
race transformation as morality play
in the 1940s a series of popular columns
ran in negro digest titled if i were a
negro
it had a famous subjunctive entry by
none other than eleanor roosevelt who
averred i would have moments of great
bitterness
over the course of the next two decades
three white journalists would go on to
publish their accounts of undergoing
race transformation in order to report
on being a negro from the other side
race beagles in the land of jim crow
from 1949
john howard griffin's black like me from
1961 and grace halzel's soul sister from
1969.
at the start of his passing in reverse
as he calls it sprinkle first applies a
homemade concoction of iodine
argor oil
pure gallic acid potassium permanganate
and the juice of walnut holes
this just leaves him striped
he finally realizes the prevalence of
light skin among the black population of
the us and ops just to get a three-week
sun town before climbing aboard a jim
crow coach on a train headed south
nothing too terrible happens to him
which he perversely laments
this would be a far better story if i
could show some scars left by the
blackjack of some negro hating small
town deputy who might fail to sur
or a few bullet holes mementos of an
argument with some trigger-happy atlanta
motorman
a decade later john howard griffin
begins his scientific research study of
the negro in the south by using a drug
for treating vitiligo as well as sun
stains and a sunlamp to darken his skin
he says
i went to look at myself in the mirror a
fierce looking bald negro glared at me
from the glass he in no way resembled me
the transformation was total and
shocking i had expected to see myself
disguised but this was someone else
i was imprisoned in the flesh of an
utter stranger
all traces of the john griffin i had
been were wiped from existence
even the senses underwent a change so
profound it filled me with distress
i looked into the mirror and saw
reflected nothing of the white john
griffin's past
i knew then that i was not a disguised
white man but a newly created negro
the race transformation here is like a
gestalt switch between obliteration and
creation
it is apt that the film version of black
like me
ran as a double feature with the horror
film the hands of orlock
in which a concert pianist who receives
a hand transplant from a convicted
killer descends into homicidal madness
in both films the physical
transformation isn't a gradual or
surface matter but a wholesale
conversion at an existential even
ethical level
in griffin's unpublished journals parts
of which have now appeared one entry
finds him worrying that the physical
change will drag along with it a total
transformation of identity even interior
identity
griffin goes on to wonder if becoming a
negro will do some profound damage to my
humanity and still more terrible will
perhaps forever alter my intimate
relationships
he even goes on to imagine having sex
with his wife while he is black
his language teetering between
titillation and horror
i did not ask her if the idea excited
her equally in this weird situation
where intercourse would be legal morally
okay
but give the illusion of being a
profoundly forbidden and even monstrous
act
grace hallzell was mentored by griffin
before she began the six-month stint as
a black woman that she documented in her
book soul sister and later published
sketches of in ebony magazine
paul zell takes extreme measures with
her transformation two corrective
treatments for vitilego plus a tanning
spell in mexico so intense that she
develops infected blisters on her second
day in harlem
when a black diner offers to help her
with her ailment she is overcome by the
imbalance of mercy between them it's
apparently only supposed to tilt the
other way
i came here to know you for what you are
you beast you black black black man and
you are ugly to me and you feel sorry
for me you are pitying me you are christ
in heaven you are loving me it is not
supposed to be like that god how i need
you how i want you
today these putatively empathic efforts
by white writers to understand what it
is like to be black in america look like
acts of self-serving and voyeuristic
self-victimization
in black for a day white fantasies of
race and empathy where alicia gains
talks about these three journalists she
notes
that their brand of empathy not only
refuses to challenge the reality of
black second-class citizenship it
actually requires it
gaines also cites bell hooks's earlier
analysis of the voracious appetite of
white racism which can turn even empathy
into quote eating the other
in a world of white supremacy hooks
writes desires for the primitive or
fantasies about the other can be
continually exploited in a manner that
reinscribes the status quo
white racial surrogacy in fact relies on
the assumption that black suffering is
not legible not real not worthy of
redress until it is experienced and
articulated by a white person
as sidea hartman puts it in scenes of
subjection
can the white witness of the spectacle
of suffering affirm the materiality of
black sentience only by feeling for
himself
the masochism of becoming black isn't
just a way to assuage white guilt it is
also a surreptitious way to flaunt one's
ability to survive racism it's not so
bad if i made it out alive
as well as one's presumptive prerogative
to get out to invoke jordan kiel's film
which i'll discuss later
in short the immediacy transience and
opportunism of race transformation
encourages a
self-congratulatory self-fulfilling
return to whiteness in some sense it's
as though these figures need to go
across the line in in order to
consolidate whiteness by returning to it
these writers are in some ways like the
minstrel performers who as david
roediger writes in wages of whiteness
claimed the right to turn black for as
long as they desired and to reappear as
white
these non-fiction memoirs betray a
desire for the monstrous consequences of
racial surrogacy
that still relies on being able to
escape those consequences
the wish to expose self-evident racism
comes to look a lot like a desire for
suffering
halzel breathlessly anticipates being
raped by both black men and black women
i went with trembling heart to the
ghetto harlem fearful that a big black
bogeyman might tear down the paper thin
door separating my white body from his
lustful desires
alicia gaines notes the irony that
halzel actually quit the project when a
white man assaulted her
griffin's book evolved out of a series
in the magazine sepia
which began with a piece entitled
journey into shame
implying of course a journey back out
the pleasure and the penance of race
transformation are entwined the racist
white person secretly yearns to be
whipped and what better way than to
become black but as gaines wisely notes
in her title only for a day
the 1986 film soul man captures this
amalgam of resentment guilt and
entitlement
a white student takes tanning pills to
make himself eligible for a scholarship
for black students at harvard law
he falls in love with a really black
single mom
who was as it happens the runner-up for
the scholarship he got
the jokes are automatic
he plays basketball badly
he flirts with stereotypes
his preference in music turns to the
soulful
he has sex with a white woman who
exoticizes his penis
he eventually confesses promises to
donate to civil rights groups punches a
couple of racists and is bestowed with
this blessing from his really black
professor
you've learned something i can't teach
you've learned what it feels like to be
black
our penitent gets the girl gets to stay
gets an a minus
one can't help but feel that as a minor
character snarks this whole thing is an
argument against these affirmative
action scholarships
the irony of the penance arc in race
transformation whether inflicted on the
self or on others
is that it ends up skewing the equality
implied by race transformation in the
first place
you might think that the upshot as in dr
seuss's the speeches
would be that the plain belly sneetches
and the star belly sneetches are the
same inside
if only the planes and the stars could
understand each other
could understand what it's like to be in
each other's skin
everything would be fair
but real life is haunted with hidden
forms of asymmetry and injustice
consider the etymological origin of the
word fair
thus we find the curious fact that in
all the american race transformations
i've encountered
while both white and black people swap
skins for pleasure or for pliving or for
privilege
i found no black person ever turned
white as a punishment
it is somehow inconceivable that to
become white could ever be undesirable
the obverse implication is that to be
white yet able to turn black at will is
to have it all
you get to be white you get to be black
and if experiencing racism humbles you
that's all to the good too a moral
improvement
one of the oddities of the stories that
we've considered in exhibit a
are that the stories often capitalize on
the language of speculative fiction
the gothic science fiction fantasy
sprinkle connects his memoir to a
fantastical tradition in which the hero
wants to turn quote hindu or arab or one
of the other darker races and goes to an
old woman and she gives him a lotion
that turns him dark for weeks or months
he finds that being a black man is as
bewildering as if i had been dropped on
the moon
and his fellow whites soon become a
people entirely alien to me
for halsell it is a black woman's guest
house that she finds alien its residents
she imagines have lived their lives on
one planet
so to speak while she has lived on
another
playing black makes her feel like a
spook among spooks disembodied a cipher
floating in the void and a vessel for
sorts for
two sorts of personalities two sets of
eyes two bodies
this language emphasizes the magic and
the surrealism of race transformation
but also as temporariness the spell can
be broken
the charm undone
the race transformation
transformer the race transformer safely
returned to a utopian no place like home
from the alien planet that they visited
the literary critic taylor evans calls
the speculative genre that these texts
are borrowing from techno passing
stories that have as their technological
novum a fantastical technology that
changes one's appearance from
phenotypically white to phenotypically
black or vice versa
and with this i present to you exhibit b
speculative race transformation
in an archetypal plot you change your
race through some fantastical or science
fictional gimmick that either transforms
your body or transfers your soul into a
body of another race
in these tales
melodrama and minstrelsy are fused into
a magical presto effect
speculative race transformation speeds
up the melancholy melodramatic lingerie
of racial passing
a better term for the genre would be
racial switching
the race transformation is intense
immediate often violent
in typical american fashion
the fact of your racial fate the stain
or bleach that results from
miscegenation is turned into an act of
racial will
narrating the ability to turn your race
on or off with the flip of a switch
tends towards certain aesthetic effects
chemical or electric catalytic or
kinetic energy
a compression of time whether that's
through time travel identity swapping or
simultaneity or the simply the fact of
rapid change
we also get an overturning of binaries
through slapstick and satire
the quasi-scientific techniques that
these narratives invent
make the process of race transformation
quick
topsy-turvy and most importantly
reversible
both in the sense that you can undo it
and in the sense that you can switch in
either direction from black to white or
white to black
classic works of speculative fiction
have often flirted with slavery the
etymology of the word robot is robota a
czech word for forced labor
we don't have to look too far outside
the familiar canon to find the specific
fantasy of race transformation in these
texts either
in one sequence of robert louis
stevenson's the strange case of dr
jekyll and mr hyde from 1887
the hero spends the night carousing as
high then takes an elixir to return to
his more respectable avatar
but in his sleep he unknowingly relapses
into his deviant double and wakes to see
a hand on the bedspread
the hand of henry jekyll he reminds us
was professional in shape and size it
was large firm white and calmly
but the hand which i now saw was lean
corded knuckly of a dusky pallor and
thickly shaded with a smart growth of
hair it was the hand of edward high
hyde throughout the novel is an amalgam
of othernesses
he is small
ugly
queer
dwarfish
hardly human
ape-like
monstrous
a juggernaut
a troglodyte
and a savage
the phrase used for the strange hole
that hide whose name no doubts puns on
animal skin
has over jekyll
i fell in slavery
witnesses see h.g wells as invisible man
as
black
just blackness black as my hat
but also as a man with a pink and white
face and red eyes and as piebald
black here and white there
a kind of half breed whose colors come
off patchy instead of mixing
the invisal man the invisible man thinks
of himself as a gaunt black figure and
at one point makes this
comparison we later learn that he is in
fact white with the whiteness of
albinism
a condition that facilitates his
transformation
one could make an animal a tissue
transparent one could make it invisible
all except the pigments i could be
invisible i said suddenly realizing what
it meant to be an albino with such
knowledge
these quasi-scientific bases for race
transformation recur in american pulp
stories of technopassing
apart from albinism
we find vitiligo or leukoderma a real
medical condition in which the skin
loses its pigment cells as well as
melanosis a real biological phenomenon
in which as the story pigs pigments is
pigments puts it
the arctic fox the american varying hair
the ptarmigan and other mammals always
turn black in the summer being white all
winter
david h keller's the menace a 1928
four-part novella published in amazing
stories pits a humble white detective
named teen against a group of elite
power hungry harlemites called the
powerful ones
they were all negroes banded together
for the total subjection and if
necessary destruction of the caucasian
race
these wicked quote white negroes having
determined that the difference between
the negative and the white is mainly a
matter of pigment
invent a serum that turns black people
white
our physicians inject one drop of serum
into the child at birth and any tendency
to develop pigment is at once checked
tein uncovers the harlemite's plot to
convert sea water into fake gold
and their plan to infiltrate the water
supply with a chemical powder that will
turn white people black
tein's success in thwarting these
elaborate plots over the course of many
many years seems to stem from a natural
superiority which the story assumes
the white negroes can never attain true
superiority no matter their uh their
alchemy
your race can change the color of their
skins but they cannot change the color
of their souls no matter how white they
may become they will always remain black
inside
in the 1930 story dr immortelle also
published in amazing stories
the narrator has undergone an experiment
in immortality
the gradual loss of most of my own blood
and the substitution of caucasian blood
through the process of transfusion
blood becomes a literal vehicle for race
transformation but also a metaphorical
one for a set of familiar eugenic
assumptions about as the story puts it
the negro race being inferior to the
caucasian
a white love interest in the story has
quote a lilly white soul while the
formerly enslaved black dr immortelle
has
a soul as black as my face once was he
also has a passionate desire for
offspring and a tendency toward inertia
all because he still retains
a drop of negroid blood in his veins
swapping a soul into the body of a
different race is a device called
identity transfer and it's a common
science fictional mechanism for race
transformation
this is the basis for harry stephen
keeler's posthumously published the man
who changed his skin which was
originally written in the 30s
in this novel a 19th century white
bostonian receives a jet black palette
of oguva gum from a homeless man
the homeless man claims he got it from
an african tree that sprouted from a
celestial seed planted by a meteor
if you swallow it he says your soul
spirit and mind will slide off into the
carcass of somebody else
the bostonian takes the pellet and wakes
up like dr jekyll to an unexpected sight
at the end of his sleeve
the hand was black as coal my god i am
somebody other than who i was
over time the science fictional
procedures seem to grow more
sophisticated
identity transfer
becomes literalized in the form of brain
transplants as in the 1969 film change
of mind
to investigate a murder a white lawyer's
brain is placed in the body of a black
man
the tagline asks is he a white man with
a black man's body or a black man with a
white man's brain
in jess rose 2014 novel your face in
mind
not just the skin but other features too
are transformed through what's called
racial reassignment surgery so named to
emphasize its resonance with sexual
reassignment surgery
a man who claims to have had racial
identity dysphoria undergoes
a series of facial surgeries scalp
surgeries body sculpting procedures and
pigmentation treatments transforming me
from my original appearance as a
caucasian jewish white male into a
convincing african-american
while the scientific techniques for race
transformation in these texts seem to
advance
the stories remain stuck in an old
mysticism of racial essentialism
the idea that black and white features
carry inherent values like beauty or
intelligence
essentialism also gives us the feeling
that race subsists in the soul and that
people can be born in the wrong race
these contradictions should be familiar
to to you from american racial politics
race in america is somehow both surface
and depth
construct and essence
transmutable yet fixed
a contingent phenomenon with manifest
effects
a fantasy and a reality
it's a chess game that insists on an
equal distribution of black and white
elements but in which white just happens
to go first
the paradoxical sense that some magic
has bestowed incalculable value upon
something with no intrinsic worth is
hardly strange though
we engage with something that fits this
description every day
money
capitalism's magic transforms coins and
cash making them both fungible and
abstract
indices of the values of other things
this isn't a mere analogy between money
and race money gleams and rustles
throughout race transformation tales
the x-colored man who sold his
birthright when he chose to pass wears a
10 gold coin that his white father
bequeathed to him
in the menace the evil harlemites
alchemize black to white and white to
black but also sea water to false gold
and in pigments as pigments a malevolent
millionaire is turned from white to coal
ebony black and then from black to a
white as alabaster albino by a biologist
why because he scammed him out of money
these stories know that in america race
is money
if one race black people
was essentially invented in order to be
bought sold used and enjoyed at will
the desire to transform oneself into
that race even imaginatively amounts to
the capitalist impulse to own
as tony morrison notes in playing in the
dark the saved population it could be
and was assumed offered itself up as
serg itself
black people have so long been deemed to
be property that to put race on and take
it off becomes akin to consumerism
this is clear when it comes to the
contemporary techno minstrelsy of black
fishing which is the phenomenon of
non-black people using bronzer tanning
photoshop
and or cosmetic surgery to appear black
especially on social media
now some might claim that this desire to
cosplay another race is an innocent form
of allophilia
an affinity for otherness or liking
people who are different from you
but race transformation tales are always
grounded in familiar stereotypes and
this begs the question of otherness of
diversity
in short racial otherness somehow always
looks the same it is a brand you wear so
to speak
and so we find that the value of
whiteness in race transformation tales
always seems to manifest in abstract
aspects of personhood like safety
status and purchasing power
the value of blackness
by contrast has long been cast as
physical
as sensual
even bestial
for some reason the two disney animated
movies that feature black protagonists
the princess and the frog and soul
magically place both of those
protagonists inside an animal for much
of the plot
a disconcerting number of race
transformation tales intimate that being
a black man is correlated with having a
large and skillful penis an erotic
obsession that is tinged with fear and
resentment it's just as often implied
that becoming black bestows the ability
to dance to play or appreciate music and
to excel at sports
in a 2005 episode of south park kyle has
a quote negroplasty to make him better
at basketball
it makes sense that in the race
transformation fantasies i've exhibited
so far all of which were created by
white authors raised the scene as a kind
of property in several senses of the
word
first race is a bodily property a set of
features affixed to the body
that require great labor or the energy
of magic to transform
second race is assumed to be attached to
the individual subject to their
so-called proper self
whose relationship to the property of
land or wealth is often determined by
their race
and third race can be owned it is itself
property to be bought or sold it can be
pegged to a market value like gold it is
a form of capital that is seen as
fungible and abstract but can be hoarded
speculative race transformation stories
thus offer evidence
for the argument that the legal scholar
cheryl i harris made in 1993.
whiteness initially constructed as a
form of racial identity evolved into a
form of property historically and
presently acknowledged and protected in
american law
following the period of slavery and
conquest whiteness became the basis of
racialized privilege a type of status in
which white racial identity provided the
basis
for allocating societal benefits both
private and public and character
these arrangements were ratified and
legitimated in law as a type of status
property
race is not strictly arbitrary but it
has always been subject to arbitration
contingent on the law in america
we can see all of these racial logics
passing
currents
perversity and property
come together in a recent specimen of
speculative race transformation
matt ruff's 2016 book lovecraft country
entwines a history of the jim crow 1950s
with a pulp subtext
in a chapter called jekyll in hyde park
roof revisits and reverses robert louis
stevenson's race transformation scene
a woman named ruby curvy and dark wakes
in an unfamiliar bed on what appear to
be blood slick sheets
in terror she stumbles to a bathroom
splashes water on herself then opens her
eyes to see
quote a crazed white woman's face
hovering in the dark just inches from
her own
ruby screamed the white woman in the
mirror screamed with her ruby clapped
her hands over her mouth the white woman
aped the gesture the white woman her
the 2020 hbo adaptation of the book
lovecraft country
repeats the sequence
but goes on to mix its messages
adopting
a radical narrative logic that yet runs
up against a stereotyped visual logic
race as in dr immortelle is in the blood
in the novel
blood seeps up under ruby's nails
whenever she starts to slip back to
black
a white woman's blood is a key
ingredient of the elixir that transforms
her
in the show the blood is thicker more
literal more gruesome
indeed ruby doesn't turn white so much
as she wears a tight white flesh suit
inside which she shimmies seductively
dancing being in her blood then seems to
burst out of her real body being
naturally curvy and eventually rips off
and
in
dripping strips and chunks
to transform your race comes to seem
laborious
perverse grotesque as perhaps it should
but it also comes to seem vengeful in
the scene i just showed you
ruby starts out wearing her white skin
in order to apply for a dream job but
winds up tying up her racist handsy
white manager and then
murdering him with a stiletto
the white skin
of hillary that ruby adopts is
essentially a temporary disguise
that grants her access or perhaps
permission to release some energy
savagery which is here marked as black
the contradiction at the core of race
transformation erupts as a clash between
the show's narrative logic race can be
swapped at will and it's visual logic
where blackness is violent whiteness is
delicate
in writing his novel
roof said he wished to redress the
troubling history of race in genre
fiction
one of the many forms of exclusion
african americans faced was being shut
out of the popular imagination
for as long as genre fiction has existed
there have been black genre fiction fans
but most of the time they were either
ignored or insulted
he says that he wanted to give black
people a chance to star in their own
personal weird tale of course tales of
the supernatural are just a lot of fun
there's a reason african americans
wanted a chance to play too
misha green the black showrunner of the
hbo adaptation concurs what matt was
doing in the book
was reclaiming genre spaces for people
who have typically been left out of them
these well-meaning creators forget or
perhaps don't know that while black
people may have been denied the artistic
privileges afforded to white people
blackness has long been the ground of
american music film and literature
they've always been playing too
as morrison writes
black slavery enriched the country's
creative possibilities the result was a
playground for the imagination
a 21st century liberal rhetic rhetoric
of inclusion ends up centering whiteness
as a kind of historical default
included by whom
but it only does the through an erasure
of this cultural history
it doesn't seem to recognize for
instance that black people have long
been writing their own weird and
supernatural tales
indeed black writers invented race
transformation not just before matt ruth
but before robert louis stevenson even
took up his pen
and so we come to our final event
exhibit c
black speculative
race transformation
hannah crafts the bondwoman's narrative
has been authenticated as the first
novel written by an african-american
woman
it was first published in 2002 but was
likely written in the 1850s
it includes a highly amusing scene in
which a black enslaved woman herself so
light-skinned that she can pass tricks
her putatively white mistress into
applying an italian face powder that
briefly turns the skin black
the powder certainly is white and yet it
may possess such chemical properties as
occasion blackness
indeed i recently saw in the newspaper
some accounts of a chemist who having
been jilted by a lady very liberal in
the application of powder to her face
had invented as a method of revenge a
certain kind of smelling bottles of
which the fumes would suddenly blacken
the whitest skin provided the said
cosmetic had been previously applied
professor gates identified two
scientific american articles to which
hannah crafts would have had access both
of which mention a white silver nitrate
powder that in the presence of ammonia
turns black
it turns out that one of our most
important sociologists and theorists of
race none other than w.e.b du bois also
drafted a race transformation tale when
he was an undergraduate at harvard in
1889.
the story's narrator
a kind of hustler tells a white man
after a painless operation performed by
one of my friends you will appear as a
negro a full-fledged [ __ ] we will then
set out through the land of the free and
the home of the brave
after the transformation he's told your
anglo-saxon lips of the pretty red
pouting variety have gained thickness
with color your hair with becoming
modesty has slunk back cringing ashamed
either of the owner or of its owner's
owners
and your countenance which before the
application of prepared lamp black was
open and winning has suddenly become to
the last degree repulsive
presto
the temporary transformation exposes
this white student to the condescension
and derision of harvard faculty students
and staff which presumably du bois was
experiencing at the time
yet there are advantages into the
so-called vacation tied lark into the
negro point of view
you step into a new and to most people
entirely unknown region of the universe
you will be in a position to solve in a
measure the problems of introspection
and the fourth dimension
in this early speculative satire being
black offers a double consciousness a
second sight that is not only social but
seems existential
another barely studied text by a black
author there are only 22 extant copies
in the world is robert gilbert wells
self-published 1905 anthropology applied
to the american white man and negro
this text is extraordinary it includes
collages and photographs
as well as a scene of race
transformation
a formerly enslaved man named sam uses a
potion to turn his white former master
mr jones black
and that the image on the left is
precisely of that moment
by the time he had caught his breath he
was out of the door of the white man's
coach and thrown headlong into the
negros jim crow car mangled and bleeding
sam had heard the racket and was
watching what is commonly known as the
white man's fun and method of teaching
the negro his place
after the blackened mr jones is almost
lynched for trying to talk to his white
wife and family
sam uses fluids and liquids to reverse
the transformation
in charles chestnut's story mars jeans
nightmare
mars james is a hard and cruel man
monstrous strict with his hands the
hands on his plantation seek help from
aunt peggy the conjure woman and she
gives them a goofer made of powdered
roots
it turns mars jeans black and he winds
up at his own plantation supposedly as
payment for a gambling debt
a poor white overseer whips and abuses
the new slave mercilessly
when a hexed sweet potato turns james
white again he resumes his authority as
master but fires that racist overseer
relaxes his rules and ends up with a
finer plantation
so we see again the tendency toward
pedagogical penance for the white racist
but the aim of the satire in these texts
is not to rest an eye for an eye but
rather to open eyes make people see the
world through the polarized view of
double consciousness
in george skyler's 1931 satire black no
more
max disher fresh from sexual rejection
from both his high yellow girlfriend and
a white woman in nightclub stumbles upon
the black no more procedure
this device uses electrical nutrition
and glandular control to induce and
speed up vitiligo which per the novel
absolutely removes skin pigment and
turns a negro completely white
enough people use the black no more that
american social hierarchy is overturned
leaders of black communities and white
supremacist organizations both riot
politicians are rousted and institutions
raised
to be white becomes a sure sign you were
once really black newborns and genealogy
charts are scrutinized for any hint of
blackness which becomes a matter of
descent rather than appearance
black no more soon tumbles into a
jumbling of too many shades to keep
track of or to rank
soon enough a proto-tanning lotion
called an egyptian stain becomes a
bestseller and the most popular tint is
the zulu tan
an instructive juxtaposition is evident
in the production history of the 1970
film watermelon man
in hermann rusher's script a racist
white insurance salesman wakes up black
hysteria ensues screams tears mobs he
desperately tries to blanch his skin
with floods of milk soap and bleach
his liberal wife stays level-headed
it would serve you right with that
attitude of white supremacy
is it a nightmare is it his son lamp is
it a medical condition it turns out he's
just black having grown belatedly into
his family lineage
the black director of this movie melvin
van peebles who just died yesterday i'm
so sorry to say
insisted on two changes to
the script
one
he cast a black actor godfrey cambridge
who is only briefly in whiteface at the
start
two the race transformation isn't
reversed at the end
the right the screenwriter rauscher
originally had had the white hero wake
up and realized it was all a dream
but in van people's cut the man stays
black
the denouement grows moody and somber
white neighbors threatened and bribed
the newly black hero to leave town
his wife rejects his sexual advances she
says i'm still liberal but too only to
appoint
and she absconds with their kids
eventually he starts his own black
business and joins the black community
the film ends with him leading a group
of black men
in a seeming embrace of black power
the shift between the first and the last
parts of watermelon man make the whole
an uncanny avant-garde work of art
we see the same medley of tone in
contemporary race transformation tales
by black artists
in jordan peels get out white wealthy
people buy black bodies to inhabit for
physical perks stronger tendons a longer
life and for one character a better
photographic eye implying that du bois's
second sight has become a commodity
identity transfer takes place through
the quasi-medical form of brain
transplants a coagula procedure again
invoking blood that starts with hypnosis
a spoon circling the inside of a teacup
which you can see peeled posing with
here
this procedure then moves to
transplantation a partial lobotomy and
replacement with the brain of a white
master
the film literalizes double
consciousness through medicalized
zombies who are black and white slave
and master in one body
in maurice carlos griffin's 2019
burlesque we cast a shadow the racist
condescension of his white co-workers
induces a black new orleans businessman
to dress up like a zulu chief and dance
to a dark tribal beat
we learn that he is obsessed with
earning enough copper coins to afford a
newfangled surgical procedure called
demelonization
not for himself but for his mixed-race
son whose dark birthmark threatens to
spread over his entire face
i think the recent interest in
trans-racial identity
is the reason we get a very funny
documentary style skit on donald
glover's tv show atlanta
we see an interview with a black
teenager with dark skin who believes he
is a 35 year old white man
these works of race transformation
use satire to highlight the monstrosity
of racism
especially the way that even apparently
liberal whiteness can abruptly tip into
paternalism and worse horrific violence
like white authors the black authors of
race transformation tales play with
these tropes and elaborate unfamiliar
themes sexual exoticism and disgust
penis size comes up here too or as
roofing's narrator puts it quote the
myth that all us black men were hung
like clydesdales
we also see riffs on the suggestion that
blackness is somehow closer to the body
as well as the spiritualized notion of a
racial soul
but i also think these black authored
texts offer a counter model to the idea
that race is property
if we look at the three features of this
model
we can see how black author texts undo
them
for one thing race in these stories is
not a set of fixed bodily properties
when it comes to phenotype black
communities in america have always been
heterogeneous multiple shades
shapes and textures abound
these stories render skin or hair or
features based conceptions of race
altogether absurd precisely by showing
up the fact that many white americans
have black blood in the family and vice
versa and in historical terms the
surreal one-drop rule meant that even an
enslaved person who could pass was
barred from buying whiteness and full
freedom
in short race was never a property that
black people could buy or own
we might even say that black american
cultures came into being in resistance
to property as a refusal of the very
idea of purchasing people or their ways
of speaking making art and relating to
each other blackness is in the parlance
of scholars like fred moton fugitive
this is a matter of adaptation for
cultures to survive they must be willing
to grow and change they cannot be pegged
to specific properties or values this
would constrict them or turn them into
parodies of into a parody of themselves
indeed when we take a pan-african view
of black diaspora communities we cannot
help but notice how radically inclusive
they are
welcoming biracial and multi-ethnic
people even those who had no choice in
the rape induced attenuation of their
blackness
compare this to the fastidious parsing
and policing even in the law
of who is white when it comes to
american
white
politics
so in the black conception of race
blackness cannot belong to a proper self
an individual it is always relational
and communal because it is inclusive
what black authored race transformation
tales know is that personhood and race
are not fungible but relative
if the white theory of race as being
property is emblematized by money
the black theory of race as what escapes
being property can be analogized to
something else we engage with daily time
both analogies money and time convey how
race is at once real and unreal
we impose divisions and values onto
material cash and coins
we impose divisions and values onto the
invisible passage of time
but a money metaphor for reese
is flashy fickle fluctuating a spinning
coin of value heads and tails
alternately coming to view
a time metaphor is steady ongoing and
open to contingency
a history an oscillation a process
again i want to emphasize race is not a
genetic reality but insofar as it is an
identity or a culture with real world
consequences it entails time and effort
hence the very different emphases on the
diversity
duration and difficulty of race
transformation in texts by authors of
distinct races
so a story by a white author
like keeler or keller
a journalistic account by griffin or
spriegel can make the process of
becoming black seem easy or rather
facile a matter of darkened skin
minstrel level dialect living in the
hood and so on
but then people's watermelon slows down
considerably once the protagonist learns
that he is black for good
he spends time he hangs out he learns he
grows over the years he becomes
conscious
in get out putting a white person's mind
inside a black person's body is hardly
sufficient for race transformation
their bodies stay black and sliver of
their black consciousness remains
emerging from the sunken place in brief
emotional glimpses
tears anger and abrupt warnings for the
hero to get out
we come to understand that blackness
isn't reducible to the body but is
rather something that comes from
experience over time
something that lasts
this is conveyed in the film through the
black heroes literally salvific
relationship with his black best friend
rod
in sum
speculative race transformation tries to
short-circuit the time of racial passing
to take a shortcut
to the pleasure pain passion and
perversity of race
in so doing it sure changes the way race
can be an experience of culture and
community
one that can only happen in time over
time and through time
it is an experience that we would want
not to get out from but to move deeper
into move gradually with
rather than purse passing
rather than reverse passing
rather than switching between races and
rather indulge in barnum's taxonomic
barking perhaps we might treat race as
what i hope this talk has provoked a
contingent curious and ongoing movement
of the mind
thank you so much
thank you very much now molly this is
the place where there would be
thunderous applause that we weren't in
this zoom
strange space
thank you for taking us through a truly
bizarre corpus
and with unfortunately familiar
horrors lurking behind it so i
appreciate that i want to encourage
audience members to put questions into
the q a
anything you want to ask will try to
communicate that to our speaker and i
want to introduce briefly tina post
who's assistant professor in the
department of english language and
literature she's on the committee on
theater and performance studies
in the center for the study of race
politics and culture at the university
of chicago she got her phd here at yale
and performance studies
and
we do miss her
i want to point you to a monograph that
should be out very soon within the next
year or two called deadpan the
aesthetics of black inexpression
and welcome tina thanks for helping us
out thank you
so
we can run this
as we all want to i could start with one
question
i have a lot of questions and i'm really
happy you came through dubois and
double consciousness because it seemed
um
what's left out in all of these accounts
is anything like the intellectual or
consciousness
of
black experience
it's as though it reminded me of all
those pictures of einsteiner einstein
wigs as though you could put that on and
that was it
but there's a whole um
mental
experience that goes along with it does
anyone make reference to wisdom
you know
consciousness intelligence as something
you would pick up going over to the
other side
not going over to the black side no
um i mean i think du bois uh in in this
short story which is remains unpublished
he he referred to it as unprofitable um
with with the misspelling of prophet um
as in the prophetic which i think is is
quite a funny
uh accident to make
but he's the only one who says that the
white
harvard undergraduate who's been
transformed into a black person
is going to have access to the fourth
dimension which you know in in
the kind of general parlance of the time
would have meant time
um so i find that quite um
quite interesting and actually it's you
know robert gilbert wells when he
transforms
his master or x-master mr jones into a
black man
his wife is like ah you gotta change him
back he can't handle it like he he's not
like us he's you know he hasn't suffered
through being black he doesn't know how
to deal with this and he says you know
if he
were
more
if he were stronger
having access to blackness wouldn't just
be as a way of accessing suffering but
would actually be
a way of expanding his consciousness
they're engaged throughout this text in
a kind of socratic debate back and forth
about very you know um intellectual
and
social problems uh facing the country
but um
you know this transformation is meant to
be both a kind of social experiment um
mr jones learns that his own brother
is probably black um and they reunite as
a result of this transformation um but
he also you know sam really thinks if he
if he becomes black he'll have access to
to wisdom and knowledge but again it's
this is this is
striking to me that it's the black
authors who perceive this who perceive
that becoming black would not just be
about learning to dance better
you know i want to give the word over to
you
[Music]
um
i don't i don't know that i have too
much to add to that except that it's
remarkable that the one
maybe the one thing that's so consistent
between the narratives authored by um
uh white authors and those of black is
is the way in which they acknowledge
that blackness is this like
unknown country right
and i think um one of the things that um
is maybe implicitly uh march upon in
these narratives is that um historically
black people have always known white
people very very well you know we've
raised their children wash their clothes
cook their meals like we know whiteness
in a way that whiteness has never known
blackness in return and both um the
white and black authors it seemed to me
did sort of allude to the the um you
know i'm entering this unknown territory
and truly was so um
so uh yeah i guess this would be the one
the one thing i did too that's a great
observation um i think one of the ways
you can can see it is if you compare
these texts to passing literature
where there's there's not very much
um
by way of
study or effort when you pass it's it's
a choice that can happen kind of
seamlessly because you know how to live
as a white person you just have more
privileges you know
you don't have to read certain things
you don't have to whereas in these texts
when you become black there's all of
this tension about well um will i know
how to dance and will i know how to play
basketball and will it automatically
give me this um this this knowledge or
this body knowledge and there's all this
there's all this kind of like effort
that's why the the magic and the the
science fictional gimmick is necessary
in some ways because it can't just
happen naturally the way that it does in
passing
thanks that's great
tina i don't know if you want to open up
any topics at this point
um
i mean i'll say a couple things that
seem interesting to me um
uh the whole talk was wonderful first of
all thank you so much it was fascinating
and um
totally fruitful
um
there were a couple of thoughts that i
had that um or just things that came up
to me as i was reading it that i'll
maybe just put on the floor and of
course i have no way of knowing if
you're as familiar with these
um
[Music]
some of these ideas um
one is this
bonkers
like one-off movie from the 90s that's
maybe like this this historical juncture
that we may have gone down but didn't
called suture
and um
yeah okay so the presence the the
premise of this movie which all which i
saw many years ago and barely remember
but it's a black and white film
um
involving twin brothers um one of whom
is white and one of whom is black and
not like passing black just like black
and
absolutely nothing is said about it and
so there's no acknowledgement that
they're not
that they don't look
alike or consonant in any way so that
was um sort of one one thing i wanted to
toss in is um
perhaps fruitful
and then um
what was it there was one other
thing oh um i'll save the other thing
for later if it comes up it's i think
that's important but um but yeah you you
nodded as though you've seen suture so
yeah i've seen it and i i screened it
actually at a conference that i
organized at uc berkeley on faces
because
um
i was very interested in all of these
close-up shots of the face because it's
obviously also kind of troping on
h.g wells is invisible man
because you have this face that's you
know the face is damaged and is wrapped
up in all these bandages and it's slowly
unpeeled and then like when when the
suturing of the skin is happening
uh to the black face it's there's all
these very
kind of intense close-ups of that face
and so i was very interested in the
extent to which the face is the locus of
racial identity for us um but also in
the way that
the transformation of the face is
something that's presented as an
aesthetic project um and so in my book
on faces called stranger faces which was
published last year i talked about this
and a little bit in relation to michael
jackson's surgeries on his face as well
so i was interested in it in that sense
i mean that movie is interesting because
it it the there's the scientific or the
science fictional you know trope of race
transformation isn't happening in the in
the diagesis in the narrative it's
happening as you say in the in the
viewer who's given no clue as to why
this is and so you're just constantly
working against your own assumptions of
what race looks like as you watch the
film
that's terrific maybe i'll throw in a
paranoid question
and we're talking especially about um
those people who did a kind of
ethnographic study and
did the black face and and went and
wrote these books
i couldn't help think of
things like cointelpro
and other programs in which there was
infiltration and i wondered whether
there was if you thought there was a
kind of paranoia
um
fears of uprisings and whether these
were
spies
i wouldn't know i mean alicia gains this
book i relied on very heavily black four
day and it's a brilliant analysis and
she went into the archives of these
three writers and didn't seem to uncover
anything
um of that nature
and i think
but what's interesting about it is
the very
desire to publish a memoir about it and
and this idea that it's this kind of
confessional
um it's filled with all these emotions
that have to do with shame and prurience
and taboo suggests to me
um you know that they definitely weren't
spies because the whole point was
exposing this
and kind of playing off of it um
it's it's a very
even if they're not you know good spies
for the government
there's something like a race spy
reporting back in the way that tina
mentioned
to assure the white population that the
uprising is not going to happen now
true but what's interesting is that um
at least
griffin and
halsell
published parts of their work in black
oriented
magazines like sepia so the audience was
not just the white community it was also
the black community in
which feels to me like a kind of attempt
at um
atonement right you you have to know
that i tried um and it's no use to tell
you know my white liberal progressive
friends that i tried um
it's i need to i need to tell the black
community how how
deeply i went into this and how i have
suffered what they have suffered um
so it's yeah it's interesting it's it's
a they're double agents i guess
okay that does that does bring me sort
of round to the other thing that i was
thinking of mentioning and then i yeah
um jackie sibley's story's fair fairview
the play i don't know if you know it
okay so it begins with a conversation
about um well now just again but
okay yes yes there's a conversation
about what if you could change your race
who would you be and why that
happens is this um
over
um
overarching narrative over what's
happening on the stage and then uh
they're sort of list everything comes
apart and then there's
um a moment of uh meant to be
black communion and community which
seems very much in keeping with your
sense of like
uh racial relation
um and yet it spawned this whole um
what might be considered a sort of um
confessional theater review
it's like a
from all the um white
usually white theater goers who go and
review um plays for for newspapers and
um
i think it was a
it was a it was a fruitful and fraught
experience for many and uh but it
definitely needed to be sort of unpacked
um
uh and i love teaching that play because
yes there's a lot to unpack there um but
i i realize if you haven't seen it this
is perhaps unfair but but maybe you
experienced some of those kinds of
reviews and when it was big
um i i didn't read the reviews but i do
know um i do know of the play and
there is a history and i i cut this from
the the talk but in the essay i talk
about um the musical finnians rainbow
which was also turned into a film
um
directed by francis ford coppola and
which there is a scene in which a racist
white
senator is is cursed
as a
as turned into a black person again in
order to to
um force him to change his ways and so
that i think the the history within the
theater and and within film is really
interesting
um
i i didn't quite follow what the
what what is the transformation plot
that happens in
fairview
so that it's it's funny because it isn't
even actually a plot so the plot of the
play as such
there's sort of diegetic layers to it
but the plot of the play is such as sort
of a um
a black family
drama or at least it starts that way
and as the
over uh the narrative
the voices come on sort of discussing
well if you could change your race what
would it be and then of course the
answers are stereotypical
and also there's someone like pushing
against stereotypes and um and as
but the the
action on the stage becomes more and
more stereotypical as that
um
extra layer of sound is transpiring um
on top of it
um i hope that's a fair um
summary it's been i haven't haven't
reread it in a minute but that's um i
think that's a fair i mean it's so
interesting i think that um something
that i've noticed
in
and i
one way of putting it is that slide i
have or that note that i have that i
couldn't find any
black person being turned white as
punishment
um that there's
there's
the
whiteness is aspirational and the
assumption that whiteness is
aspirational
is something that pervades all of these
texts
but in the white authored texts
um there's it's not troubled it's just
sort of seen as obvious that it would be
better to be white
and this is why you know um
you have these uh
this this kind of hysteria at the idea
that you know white people could be
turned black against their will right
um
but in the black author texts
there's very much a kind of sense that
to be to be made white
is not necessarily what you want
and that there's a cost
and this is why you know we have this
history and passing literature of it
being presented as a kind of death
and and it's also something that really
fascinates me just at a kind of uh
personal level that
whenever
i'm asked about the fact that i have a
white parent
there's a kind of sometimes there's the
illusion that i could be white that i
could pass which i don't think i've ever
passed but also that i would want to and
there's always a surprise when i say i
wouldn't i would never want to be white
actually and so i think there's there's
something along those lines i think
maybe that is troubling to the reviewers
is actually even having the conversation
of whether you would want or not want to
change your race produces a kind of um
tension
because there are these assumptions that
these different people work with
thanks
that's great i want to give just a
little time to the q a and i'm going to
read you a couple of questions that okay
so one says thank you for the wonderful
talk i was wondering what you make of
the satire in black no more directed
against black activists and
intellectuals like w.e.b du bois
yeah i mean skyler is a a great
figure in some ways um
i i recommend the biography of him
written by jeff ferguson
he's a conservative in certain ways and
i think the leftist politics of that
time
kind of bothered him but i also think
there's an attempt to skewer
the uh pretensions of that of the harlem
renaissance of that community at the
time
um and of course you know one of the
things he makes a lot of
uh you know that's grist for his
satirical mill is that du bois and other
people in the harlem renaissance were
all very light-skinned du bois himself
could have passed
um so there's a kind of a sense i think
that he also wants to show up the
colorism that's implicit in both the
black and the white community um so
there's he's he's satirizing power
dynamics and hierarchies that are within
both of those of those communities so
that that's i mean it's a pretty um
i think short analysis of a really
really fascinating text but that's what
i would say about that
okay here's another one thanks for a
thought-provoking talk i totally agree
that race in quotes is experiences
through time
so you have one believer
i wonder how you would read a scenario
of a white presenting person being
embedded in a community of color and
staking a claim to the identity of color
would that be a legit identity
performance in that connection are you
familiar with david henry wang's
satire play yellow face that was made
into a youtube film
i i'm not familiar with it but um
it's interesting because this this sort
of came up uh in my in a conversation i
had yesterday when the trailer for the
new film of passing came out there's
been a lot of conversation about whether
the two actresses cast
in the film could themselves pass as
white and there's a lot i mean one of
the the
kind of tropes of passing for
the black community is that um
like if you see someone who's passing
you've got their number like you could
identify them as as black
and so
there are many people who say well the
idea that
one of these or both of these women
could pass as white um
means that they could pass as white to
other white people right
but the reason this came up is because
rebecca hall the director of the film is
herself herself has black in the family
right it turns out that her grandfather
was black
and but no one in the family had
registered or identified as black um for
her whole life so she grew up as a
white passing black person but with no
sense of being black
and she's an actress herself and so i
wondered why she didn't
um star in the film and i think even
though she i think would have been a
better casting
because she looks like she could be
white and so you might believe it she
wouldn't be as good because she doesn't
have the experience of being black which
is again this kind of cultural cultural
experience
so i i don't know i don't think a white
person living in a black community or
person who's white identifying or
you know who has no blackness in their
in their family or in their community
and who just embeds in a black community
could be said to have experienced
blackness no
um but they are they are having a
different experience than a lot of white
people for sure but you have to
understand you know what you describe in
this um in this question is is very
common it's the south i mean there are a
lot
it's a lot of co-presence of black and
white people in the south but it's still
an incredibly segregated and racially
divided uh community so
i don't think that um experience is
simply about
uh being present within a black
community
um i think and i think that staking that
identity is
very much
akin to the kinds of appropriative
gestures that i was talking about in
some of these um in some of these texts
where the the desire to belong the sense
it was just allophilia i just prefer
black people and so on that's fine and
good if you want to live your life that
way but you can't then say i am
therefore black that's not how it works
unfortunately
that is a beautiful line on which to end
okay tina give you
i'm just gonna quickly add just a couple
of things um
all i agree with everything um but i
would say
maybe maybe two additional things one is
that um
just very much
as in the talk i think one one
experience of
racialization
is
is exactly that
sense of not being able to leave when
you want to and that's one of the things
that
distinguishes um the
um
being um
a
i forget a weight identifying person who
is living a black life is that as in
those as in those fictional stories when
that person wants to stop they can
um and and that that's a critical part
of i think the black experience or
racialized experience um for many people
is that that escape hatch
there is no escape patch um the one
other thing i would say um
about that is that um
is that i think um to take amalie's
sense of time and and
and expand it over
a longer span i think um to take i hate
to utter her name but to take the rachel
doll's all example i think um
um
she had mixed race children
who
were
black and she was welcomed into the
black community not as a black person
but as a black family member and over a
couple generations
the whiteness as such would disappear
but that but to demand that the
the black time
peg itself to to a lifetime
i think that's just not how that works
um
yeah
yeah it tries to short-circuit something
that is actually like it's not just
days and weeks and months it's years and
decades and generations
um i'm seeing um some other questions
that i think i can um
uh
dispatch relatively quickly if we if we
have some time
so there's some questions about
whether plays or films that have to do
with
um people pretending to be jewish or
pretending to be a nazi um would be
included there there are some
amazing
uh race transformation in the kind of
speculative fiction sense uh tales about
becoming jewish there's a kind of
horrific
um
uh horrifically anti-semitic play that i
almost considered but i wanted to limit
this um to the question of black and
white transformation because it is so
prevalent and because there are so many
texts it was a way to narrow my scope
somewhat and also i think that the the
dynamics of religious quasi-ethnic
transformation are different than racial
transformation in the american sense um
and i'm asked if black klansmen was a
text i considered i did not because
that's simply a change of voice and it
happens over the phone the same happens
in sorry to bother you by boots riley
where um it doesn't have the science
fictional gimmick um and the the memoirs
that i looked at the nonfiction accounts
that i looked at
all used some version of some kind of
science to try to to try to transform
them
themselves one of the texts that i
almost looked at was tropic thunder
because um robert downey jr's character
is said to have undergone pigment
augmentation um which is similar to the
tanning pills in uh in soul man um but
it's such a brief
moment of transformation and he
basically appears as black throughout
the movie and so it's closer in in
effect to blackface or minstrel c
um than it is to a race transformation
text as such
um
does the assumption of race that it is a
social construct suggests that it is a
caste system
i think that there are
many people who are
interested in this idea
in sociology
um and we off we had this recent book
called cast um
uh what's her name
um wilkerson i want to say
um
but i read a review of that book that
put it into context it's in the boston
review and it's it's an excellent review
because it sort of pulls apart some of
the assumptions and also talks about the
difficulty and
and perhaps the vagueness or fuzziness
of applying
a system of caste which is kind of
external to the us onto the u.s context
um so i i would hesitate to to follow
from that i also don't think we need
cast to understand how race works we've
got a lot of analysis of how race works
as a social construct um in uh
in the history of american
theory and
sociology
and then finally
there's a question here
um
well there's two questions there's one
about teaching
these texts
and
there's also one about
journeying
i don't think i understand this one
actually um
i think the last question is asking
about um
now i have to read it again too
sorry sorry yes so so it says would it
be fair to include the going native or
white savior genre into this and i do
think that there's
those
those kinds of texts
do fall into the
race transformation as morality tale
uh subsection or
exhibit of my circus
um
but i think again
the
the the willful
transformation of the self
as opposed to
moving into a community to save it or
um or going native in a kind of
anthropological mode
are slightly distinct um they have
similar impulses behind them i do think
but i would again by trying to sort of
work with the very specific
idea of transformation of actual
physical transformation in these texts
i'm trying to get it um specifically the
way that this genre produces its own
aesthetics
specifically the the topsy turviness the
the satirical tone the immediacy the
violence of the slapstick
and also this sense of reversibility um
or being able to to to go back if you if
you're if you can um
as tina was pointing out so i was
interested in lesson embedding than in
transforming
and then okay so the final question i'll
take is about teaching these texts and
so i've taught
black no more
get out
and a bit of the robert gilbert wells
anthropology
applied to the white man and negro
i've not taught the
any of the white
authored texts before
um i was considering teaching the menace
in like juxtaposition with black no more
because they have so much in common
including the mechanism of the
transformation
and they were published you know around
the same time and they have
you know it's it it provides again a
very instructive juxtaposition like the
one i tried to give you and the script
for watermelon man versus the actual um
direction that melvin van peoples gave
it
but it's it's difficult i mean when i've
taught black science fiction before
i've taught
bradbury and i've taught
poe
as ways of uncovering what morrison
calls the kind of africanist presence in
their works
and and i've taught a little bit of
lovecraft as well to show
what it is that black science fiction
writers in some ways are writing against
and what they're working with in terms
of the shared social set of
assumptions and stereotypes
but it is it is difficult to teach ray
bradbury to undergraduates in a science
fiction course who
many of them have read bradbury and love
bradbury and for me to to point out that
actually
the story is incredibly racist um and so
you know i think i think it's useful and
i i don't believe in in cancelling these
authors i believe that it's useful to
teach them precisely with an attention
to where
they fall short and to where their they
reflect the ideology of their time and
the racism that still exists
this is how racism kind of perpetuates
itself is through
the culture through the text we read
through the things we watch
and so even when it's you know black
directors or black authors everyone is
kind of participating in this machine of
ideology production
understanding how that works is
incredibly useful for students and so
simply not reading it is not going to
help when they once they leave the
classroom and enter you know a
post-trump world um where you know we're
you know
you know just discarding haitian
refugees uh you know it's it's silly i
think to pretend that racism doesn't
exist in in the text that we read and to
banish all texts that don't um that
don't conform to the
our own politics when actually we have
to learn it in order to counter it
beautiful i'm gonna suspend here i know
there's a lot more to talk about but
thank you for taking us
for a tour through this difficult
material from the other side or the
other sides really appreciate it again
lots of applause
congratulations and thank you thank you
so much for having me have a good
evening everyone
you